SIERRA: Hi everyone.
It’s been more than two months since the
war in Ukraine began.
At first, many people assumed that the conflict
wouldn’t happen.
Then, many assumed that it would end with
a quick Russian victory.
Now, after incredible bravery by Ukrainian
armed forces, we know that we are looking
at a prolonged conflict.
Ukraine has pushed back hard.
Russia seems to have given up on Kyiv, at
least for the time being, and is preparing
for a renewed assault on the Eastern and Southern
regions of Ukraine.
Meanwhile, more than 11 million Ukrainians
are believed to have fled their homes, with
more than 5 million fleeing the country.
Casualties continue to rise.
And as focus on NATO grows, we still don’t
know whether this regional war could turn
into a war between superpowers.
With all of that in mind, we thought it was
time to sit back down with CFR president Richard
Haass.
We talked last week, and a lot has happened
since then including an official visit to
Ukraine by Secretary of State Tony Blinken
and Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin.
But I learned a lot in the conversation, and
I got to pick Richard’s brain about what
this war means, and where it's headed.
And we wanted to share that with our listeners.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, the path forward in Ukraine, with Dr.
Richard Haass.
SIERRA: Here we are again.
Richard HAASS: Good to be back.
SIERRA: Welcome back to Why It Matters, Richard
Haass.
Again, wish it was under better circumstances.
But -
HAASS: You wouldn't have me back if the circumstances
were all good.
SIERRA: That's a good point, actually.
Yeah.
That's true.
Ok let’s get right into it, so you have
a new piece out in Foreign Affairs, and in
it, you note that while Russia's goals in
this war seem pretty clear, the goals of the
West aren't very clear.
So what should our goals be and what should
we be unwilling to accept in terms of how
this war ends?
HAASS: Russia's goals, as you say, seem, and
I probably emphasize the word “seem” pretty
clear.
SIERRA: Yeah.
HAASS: You never know what's real and what's
put out, but the goals to begin with were
quite expansive, obviously was all of Ukraine
to effectively end its sovereignty, probably
establish a puppet government, that didn't
work out so well for Mr. Putin.
They seemed to have downsized their goals
significantly.
And now you see a lot of stuff about the Donbas,
a land corridor connecting Southern and Eastern
Ukraine to Crimea.
So that seems to be the current set of goals.
If they ever were to achieve them, none of
us can say with confidence, they wouldn't,
once again, revise their goals up.
SIERRA: Right.
HAASS: But I am struck by the contrast.
I don't know what our goals are.
And I've been watching this pretty closely,
you know, almost all the debate out there,
think about it - is, are we providing enough
arms?
Are we providing the right kind of arms?
Are we doing everything we can and should
be in the way of sanctions?
do in the way of bolstering NATO?
Almost all the debate that I've heard and
read has been about means.
It's not been about ends.
So what's our definition of success?
Is our definition of success, for example,
to simply end the war?
Is it to get all Russian forces out of all
of Ukraine?
Including what they gained in 2014, Crimea
and parts of the Donbas?
Is it to get back to where things were two
months ago, when this phase of the war began?
Is it to get a peace treaty?
Is it to get accountability on war crimes?
Is it to get payment for reparations?
Is it to get Vladimir Putin out of power,
when the president mused about regime change?
So here we are two months into the war and
I don’t think we have a shared definition
of success.[a] And that's really important
because in a couple of weeks, we're probably
going to be in the middle of an intense battle
in the south and the east.
And what should it inform our policy?
For some would say so long as Russia doesn't
get more than they now have, that ought to
be something we, and the Ukrainians can live
with.
Some will say that gives Russia way too much
of a reward.
And that what we ought to do is get back to
where we were in late February.
Some will say, there should not be one Russian
soldier on any square inch of Ukrainian territory.
And a lot of people have raised their war
aims because of the atrocities.
War has a way of hardening people.
And the feeling is Russia has to pay a cost
for the awful things that they've done.
So again, the question I have is what are
our war aims?
Who sets them?
Ukraine might have a different set of war
aims than the United States, which might have
a different set of war aims, say than Germany
or the EU or NATO.
And there's a lot of history here.
In 1950, when we fought a war in Korea and
originally the North Koreans did very well,
they conquered most of the peninsula, then
General McArthur landed US and UN forces at
this port called Incheon marched up to the
38th parallel.
And at that point, things were where they
had begun.
And he and President Truman made the fateful
decision, "Wow, we're on such a role.
Let's continue.
Let's try to unify the entire peninsula under
the pro Western government in Seoul."
And lots of people said, "Be careful because
as you go up toward the Chinese border, the
Chinese won't let that happen."
Hundreds of thousands of Chinese troops entered
the war, tens of thousands Americans, hundreds
of thousands of Koreans died after that.
And after several more years, things were
once again, pretty much stopped along the
38th parallel.
And I raised that because I think we need
to have a serious conversation about a couple
of possibilities.
One is that things go badly on the ground.
Just say, Russia continues to expand some
of its holdings in the Donbas, moves towards
Odessa and the rest, what more might we do
there?
What do we do to prevent that or reverse it?
What happens if Ukraine starts gaining the
upper hand?
In the first phase of the war, Ukraine did
extraordinarily well, just say they started
pushing Russian troops out of the Donbas into
Russia.
And Mr. Putin then starts to threaten escalation.
What do we do then?
Again, what do we insist on if there are talks
that begin about a cease fire?
What are our terms and so on?
It's important to have some good answers to
these questions now.
SIERRA: Yeah.
It seems like.
HAASS: The heated battle is not the best time
to start improvising.
By and large, you get in trouble when you
improvise.
History has a lot of examples of that, including
something I was involved with, with the Gulf
war.
So it's important to think this through and
my guess is there won't be consensus.
There probably won't be consensus in Ukraine.
There probably won't be consensus in the United
States in the administration.
There won't be consensus within Europe and
NATO.
And I don't want that to become something
that Mr. Putin exploits.
And so I think we need to begin talking about
these to be honest, difficult issues, about
who decides and what should be decided.
SIERRA: Right.
This is really interesting to find out, because
I feel like it's a little like that thing
where you're like, "Oh, well my parents will
know the answer and no worries."
I just assume that there's a set goal and
plan.
HAASS: One of the things I've learned over
the last few years, I don't assume anything
anymore.
About our own country, about the world.
SIERRA: Fair enough.
HAASS: And even this war, think of how many
people, even after close to 200,000 Russian
troops mobilized on Ukraine's border, "assumed"
that countries don't do that anymore.
SIERRA: Right.
HAASS: January 6th domestically, how many
of us would've assumed that kind of thing
can't happen here?
People would never not accept an election
or try to overturn it.
So I think what we're learning the hard way
is all bets are off.
Also, it's one thing in an abstract academic
way at the beginning of a conflict to say,
"Okay, here's what our war aims are."
And I've been involved in those drills in
government, but the conflict itself can change
them.
Also in this case, the conflict wasn't expected
by most people.
Remember when the United States was running
around saying, "Hey, these guys aren't just
mobilizing.
They're going to invade."
And people said "No no."
Including Zelenskyy, including President Zelenskyy.
And so it's not clear to me when this war
began, we had a set of aims because most people
didn't think it was going to come about.
And since it began for good reason, everybody's
been so focused on how to not lose the war.
Again, that's the questions of arms to provide
intelligence, training, sanctions, what have
you.
That's been the understandable focus.
This sounds like something.
Well, we'll get to that later.
So my guess is this is you have your inbox,
your outbox, and I'll get to that later box.
My hunch is that's in the, I'll get to that
later.
My point is simply, later is now.
Now that we're on the cusp of a major battle,
that could prove really significant for this
war, we have got to think about what is it
we want to bring about and what is it we want
to avoid?
What can't we live with?
And those are questions we had better ask
ourselves and more important start to answer.
SIERRA: What would it mean for it to end with
Russia gaining territory?
Does that establish a very dangerous precedent?
HAASS: My short answer would be yes.
And that would be, to me, bad for both Ukraine,
because the question is whether Ukraine was
really viable, if you had Russia in control
of large chunks of the country and you're
sitting in Kyiv in government, what kind of
autonomy and independence and sovereignty
do you really have?
How do you know Russia might not restart a
war in the afternoon?
But also if Russia were to maintain control
of lots of territory, it's obviously inconsistent
with the basic international tenant rule that
sovereignty is to be respected.
Territory is not to be acquired by force to
the extent there's a basis for order in the
world.
That's probably the most fundamental principle.
So the question is, if it's violated here,
what else might Vladimir Putin do?
What else might others do?
If they basically said he can get away with
it, how might China or somebody else read
that and say, "Wow, that's interesting."
Maybe that's a precedent for me.
So my problem with Russia succeeding, even
though they've reduced their definition of
success, apparently, I don't like it.
I don't like it for Ukraine.
I don't like it for the precedent it sets,
so I would think a reasonable goal is that
we push back.
We give Ukraine the means to push back if
at all possible to get them at least to where
things stood at the end of February before
this round of the war began.
Do you think that there's a risk of the US
and Europe just getting tired of this as it
goes on and sort of pulling back from it?
HAASS: The answer is yes.
Might not be uniform, but people will say,
"Well, we've got to focus now on something
else."
Some other crisis might come along or they
might just get tired of this.
They could get tired of things like higher
energy prices.
That's possible.
You can also have political changes in certain
countries.
So you could have different governments, they
could have very different policies and developments
on the ground will affect policy.
People will say, "Oh, it's hopeless."
Or they'll say just the opposite.
They'll say “it's too expensive.”
When people start seeing the tab.
President just announced another $800 million
dollars package of arms going to Ukraine.
But if this is a long war, which I think is
more likely than not, if there's no peace
agreement that "terminates the war," we could
be doing 800 million dollars every couple
of weeks, we could be doing several hundred
million dollars of humanitarian aid every
couple of weeks, not just us but other countries.
So this could become an extraordinarily costly,
for all the protagonists, for ourselves, as
well as for Russia.
And you could have pushback.
And that's why, again, this debate over war
aims becomes important.
Because some people are going to be saying,
it is worth fighting for, I expect there'll
be those who say, "No, it's not."
In this country, there's the historic tension
between foreign policy and domestic policy.
So-called guns versus butter.
And I would think there'll be those who are
say, "Well, we've done a lot for these people,
but what about doing more for ourselves?"
I'm not advocating that, but I would expect
we're going to hear those voices, by the way,
on both sides of the political divide.
There'll be conservatives and progressives
alike, who will likely argue that at some
point.
SIERRA: Yeah.
You said that, you know, foreign policy, doesn't
always make it to the top of people's concern
list.
HAASS: And even if it does, it doesn't stay
there.
And again, here we are after two months of
war and if you turn on lots of cable television,
this is dominating the shows, not a hundred
percent, but dominating it.
The question is will it still be in two more
months?
Or in four more months and so forth?
So I have my doubts.
And a lot will also, though, depend upon the
nature of the fighting.
What's also really affected things has been
the atrocities.
There's been a human quality to this war that
this is not a battlefield war indeed.
Central to Russian strategy has to make it
anything but a battlefield war, but instead
to target civilians in cities.
And so when civilians living in cities elsewhere
in the world see that, they have an identification
with this.
This is not in that sense a traditional war
between armies, there's that dimension.
And we're going to see it intensively in the
south and east in the coming weeks.
But this is also a war where missiles and
artillery shells are being fired against civilians
living in towns and cities.
So when people in Europe in particular see
that, but also in this country, there's an
understandable, “oh my God” reaction.
SIERRA: And we are seeing it.
We're seeing it as it happens on TikTok and
different platforms.
HAASS: Exactly right.
Again, exactly right.
So this is monstrous.
This is barbaric and people therefore feel
we've got to do things.
And I actually think that's had a lot to do
with the Western reaction.
It's interesting if you read the debate in
Germany, the big loophole in the sanctions
is that the Germans still haven't shut off
their gas imports.
And the question is these images, and we’re
now seeing these terrible stories out of Mariupol
about these large trenches with hundreds or
even thousands of innocent people killed and
put in them, is whether this affects the calculus
in Germany and people say, "Hey, I know it
would be incredibly costly to our economy
if we were to shut off or dramatically reduce
imports of Russian gas, but we have to because
we're financing this war."
And it'll be very interesting to watch that
debate.
SIERRA: Well thinking of natural gas and oil
and energy, it feels like the west is sanctioning
Russia but also still buying its energy, doesn't
that play against itself?
HAASS: The short answer is yes.
Russia's main export is energy, coal, oil,
gas.
Coal and oil are essentially global commodities.
Because you put them on a tanker, you put
them on a barge and you can send them anywhere.
You can't send them to Europe, you can send
them somewhere else.
And that's what's happening.
The sanctions against Russia are not universally
supported, indeed, just the opposite.
A clear majority, an overwhelming majority
of the world's countries, are not supporting
sanctions.
I don't know if it's two thirds or three quarters
or four fifths, but out of 190 or so countries
in the United Nations General Assembly, I'd
be surprised if more than 50 or so, were supporting
sanctions.
So Russia is still able to offload its oil.
Russia's still offloading its coal and oil,
even though we're not importing any energy
from Russia.
And even though the Europeans have announced,
they're no longer accepting coal, I think
they're in the process of no longer accepting
oil.
Gas though is different.
Gas is not easily moved around.
Either you have to have pipelines to ship
it or you have to liquefy it, put it on boats
and then un-liquify it.
That is easier said than, and to build up
the capacity to do the latter, either one
can take years.
Either you have to build new pipelines or
you've got to build ways of liquefying and
both exporting and importing the gas.
HAASS: So that's the one commodity Russia
exports that makes hundreds of millions of
dollars a day from, that Europe can't find,
in near term, a substitute for.
And at the moment have not been willing to
go without.
But we are financing this war.
Russia is making well over $500 million a
day.
So whatever the costs of the war, whatever
the costs of the sanctions, Russia's doing
okay.
It can sustain a long war in particular because
the price of energy, even though it's come
down a little bit in the last couple of days,
has gone up dramatically over the course of
the last year.
So Russia can actually export less energy,
but still get as much or even more money for
it, given that the price is going up.
SIERRA: To go back to something dark that
you mentioned, you know, there are a lot of
atrocities going on.
So there's been a lot of coverage on war crimes
and I'm still trying to figure it out.
So Russia seems to have like no guardrails
in this war and the attacks against civilians
have been, as you said, brutal and ruthless.
But war is brutal and ruthless, right?
So where does the distinction lie between
war and war crimes?
And also when is the time to talk about this?
HAASS: Okay.
Two good questions.
There are rules and codes and laws of war.
What we're seeing now is a violation of every
one of them.
War is meant to be fought between combatants,
people in uniform, on battlefield, with proportionality
and so forth.
Lots of traditions, religious and legal traditions,
to do this.
You are not supposed to target non-combatants.
Now it's one thing if it happens accidentally,
this is not accidentally.
Accidents don't happen six times a day.
Accidents may happen once or twice.
This is the purposeful, intentional targeting.
So this is a war crime.
And what we're also seeing is unlawful treatment
of people who are taken, these mass executions.
This is happening with a regularity and on
a scale, this is not an improvisation.
This is clearly ordered.
So let's just say that.
The question then is what do you do about
it?
And I would say, I don't know any way of doing
something about it now.
And I hope that doesn't sound bad or callous
because again, it's horrific, these images,
it's hard to sleep after you see them.
The problem is the Russians are doing it.
It's central to their strategy.
So until we can stop the war, I don't know
how we stop this.
Now the day will come and it should come where
there's accountability and that's why there's
War Crimes Tribunals, and the rest.
And you gather the evidence, and ultimately
there's international court of law, but that
always comes afterwards, often years after
this.
You[c] can talk about it now and you can document
it now, both to prepare for that day.
Also, hopefully it will discourage or deter
some individuals on the Russian side from
participating in these activities because
they will be held accountable.
But I don't see a lot of evidence of that.
They're going to say they were ordered or
they're more frightened about not following
the orders than they are about being held
accountable down the road.
So I don't have any answers for you.
And I think the best thing that can be done
is to fight the wars effectively is it can
be fought, to end the wars as soon as it can
be ended.
And then we can turn to this, but I don't
see any way to effectively address this now.
SIERRA: Even though it's being recorded, even
though it's being shared?
HAASS: Even though it's being recorded, even
though it's being shared, even though it is
as horrific as it is.
Again, it's not incidental to the Russian
style of war.
In some ways it is the Russian style of war.
SIERRA: Ok.
Well then on the other hand let’s talk about
the Ukrainian style of war.
They seem to be doing well - better than anyone
expected.
And, with all respect to their bravery, I
want to ask you, why is Ukraine doing so well?
HAASS: Well, some of the reasons are accrued
to Ukraine itself, the leadership, the spirit,
the motivation.
Armies are not just about what's called orders
of battle, the number of tanks and Howitzers
and planes and the rest.
It's also about the commitment of the troops,
the cause, the quality of leadership.
And I think there, they have clear advantages
over the Russians.
They're obviously getting enormous material
help from the United States and NATO and other
countries.
We've also helped them with two other things.
One is intelligence, they are getting regular
inputs of intelligence.
I don't think all these Russian Generals have
simply met their end coincidentally, I think
there's been some pretty good intelligence
support with that.
And then also training.
It wasn't talked about a whole lot, but the
2014 experience when Russia took Crimea and
entered the Donbas, it showed the disparity
between Russia and Ukraine and Ukrainians
knew they had a real problem on their hands.
And quietly, but consistently over these eight
years, there's been a large training effort,
largely from the United States, also some
others to really help Ukraine improve the
quality of its armed forces, changed a lot
of the management and leadership structures,
almost the culture, the way I'd put it.
And in some ways became less Soviet, less
top heavy, less anti-initiative and much more
adaptive and flexible, a little bit more like
the American model.
And I think we're seeing some of the dividends
of having done that.
SIERRA: I have a question that I don't think
we touched on last time and I've been hearing
less and less about it, but it was something
that we all were taught to be scared of, which
is Russian hacking.
And I've heard they were really good at hacking,
but it doesn't seem like we've seen major
cyber attacks.
So is it that this just isn't a concern anymore?
Or is it that they weren't as good as we thought?
HAASS: It's curious.
The old Sherlock Holmes line about it's the
dog that didn't bark in the night.
This is what hasn't happened that so many
people including me expected.
And traditionally, if you were going to put
on a piece of paper, Russia's comparative
advantages, we would've put cyber.
Mr. Putin does not seem to be the kind of
guy who holds back.
So why don't we see a lot out of cyber?
So either they're not as good as we thought,
we're better protected than we thought, or
he's worried about our ability to retaliate.
I don't know the answer to that, but I am
struck by what hasn't, or at least appears
to have happened there.
You also read lots of stories about how Ukraine
has been really good at organizing with international
as well as domestic support there, almost
a counter hacking.
SIERRA: Right.
Yeah.
HAASS: Which has been helping their defenses,
but also going, so I don't know if the Russians
have been simply pushed on the back of their
feet and off balance or some combination of
all these things, but you're right.
If you had asked me, would we be two months
into the war and we would not have seen massive
cyber attacks?
I would've said no, we would've seen them.
And so it's striking by its absence.
SIERRA: In line with that, it seems like a
lot of coverage has just been expressing surprise
that Russia isn't doing better.
So does that sort of mean that Russia is weaker
than we kind of thought.
HAASS: I think the answer is yes.
And again, that'll be an interesting thing
afterwards, which is why did both Western
intelligence and Vladimir Putin both overestimate
the strength of the Russian military?
And he was getting fed presumably bad information.
Obviously, there's more corruption, a lot
of the money wasn't going to certain things.
A lot of things don't seem to work.
The failure rate appears to be extraordinarily
high, the quality or lack of it, of military
leadership, the Russians are also, they seem
to be, if you think about Russian history,
much better at resisting invasion than invading.
They're not good at improvising.
They get very locked into…
And again, this is not a culture politically
and otherwise we're improvisation, shall we
say is rewarded.
So for a lot of different reasons, they're
doing worse than pretty much anybody predicted.
So I think we need to go back and basically
ask, why did we get that wrong?
And what does this tell us about the future?
Because I think it's part of the explanation
of why Russia after this war, whenever that
day comes, or if this war continues against
the backdrop of this war is going to be weaker,
then we thought.
I'd love to know, and I don't know the answer
to this, what the Chinese make of it.
About what the Chinese not just make of the
Russians, but whether this has forced them
in some ways to reexamine themselves.
SIERRA: Oh really?
HAASS: What are their assumptions about their
abilities?
I mean, think about it.
What's the biggest strategic goal of China?
Taiwan.
What hasn't China ever done?
A large amphibious operation.
So what do they assume about their abilities
to fight a war?
How confident are they of their own estimates
of their own capabilities?
And so this has taught us again to, to be
somewhat skeptical of assumptions and to ask
questions.
And I'm hoping the US intelligence community,
when all is done, does an after action report
or a so-called postmortem and looks at it
and says, "Okay.
Where were we right?
Where were we wrong and why?
What does that tell us about things like confirmation
bias, about assumptions?
Is it that we didn't have the right information
or is it that we interpreted the information
we had incorrectly?"
I'll be really interested in that.
SIERRA: All right Richard Haass, we’re coming
to the end, so I have to ask why does the
war in Ukraine still matter?
HAASS: It should matter for several reasons.
One is the humanitarian.
It's hard to watch this and not have an answer
to that question.
It may not affect people directly in terms
of affecting our lives, our work, our families,
but as a human being, it's hard to watch this
and not be moved or outraged or some combination
of all of that.
Second of all, when president Zelenskyy says,
"We're fighting for all of you," he's right.
If Russia isn't stopped in Ukraine, does anyone
think that Mr. Putin is the kind of guy who
self-stops?
I don't think so.
I think he pushes and where he finds weakness,
he continues to push.
Where there's pushback, he stops.
In the Ukraine, for example, he's again, revised
his goals down because he met with extraordinary
resistance.
But why does anyone think for a second he
wouldn't revise them up?
And the indirect thing, when the North Koreans,
the Chinese, the Iranians terrorist groups
and all that, they look at this and they go,
"Okay.
What does this tell us?"
And if we don't stand up here, why do people
think they won't be more likely to challenge
us?
And then there's things like energy, there's
connections, supply chains.
So this has all sorts of economic consequences.
I think consequences for war and peace, obviously
human consequences.
So I think this is a good example, this may
be 4,000 miles away, whatever the distance
is, 5,000 miles away, but it's a good example
that things can, and do matter.
Two months ago, Gabby, very few of us could
have looked and either found Ukraine on the
map, or even if we found it could have said,
"This is Odessa.
This is Mariupol.
This is Lviv.
This is Kyiv."
We didn't even pronounce it Kyiv several months
ago.
And I think what we're learning is that this
country in the center of Europe, the cities
in that country, we are now beginning to see
the associations between what happens there
and what happens elsewhere in the world and
including here.
So yeah, that's why it matters.
SIERRA: Well, this has been great and you
know always good hanging with you.
HAASS: I look forward to coming on your show
one day and where we can leave people happier
at the end than they were at the beginning.
SIERRA: All right.
So we'll plan for that in the future.
HAASS: We'll just leave it out there as a
tease for people.
SIERRA: Thank you.
HAASS: Thanks.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed and we
really do appreciate it.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
Our intern this semester is Roshni Rangwani.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire/Kali and Natalia Lopez.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Jeff Reinke and our co-creator
Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!